[موسيقى]
مؤتمر المناخ كوب تونتي 7 في شرم الشيخ
واجه تحديات وصعاب عديده حتى قبل انطلاقته
فالحرب في اوروبا وارتفاع التضخم وازمه
الطاقه وازدياد حجم الديون السياديه ونقص
الغذاء والتوترات الامريكيه الصينيه كلها
مجتمعه لم تكن لتفسح المجال امام تعاون
دوليا وثيق في مكافحه الانبعاثات والتعامل
مع ذيلها فمن الواضح ان الواقع السياسي
لامن الطاقه وكلفتها فرض نفسه في
المفاوضات وخيم على المؤتمر فكل المقترحات
حول توسيع التعهد العام الماضي في كلاسكو
بالتخلي التدريجي عن الفحم ليشمل كل انواع
الوقود الاحفوري قتلت في مهدها وهذا لم
يكن نتيجه معارضه الدول المنتجه للنفط
والغاز فحسب بل لمعارضه كبر الدول
المستهلكه حيث ان ازمه الطاقه الحاليه
اكد دورا الوقود الاحفوري في مواجهه هذه
الازمه على الاقل خلال السنوات القليله
المقبله وهذا ما استدعى حذف ما اتفق عليه
في غلاسكو لعام الماضي وهو الوصول
بالانبعات الى ذروتها في عام 20 25
ماقد ينبا بتزايد الاهتمام العالمي
بتقنيات احتجاز الكربون كاحد الحلول
الضروريه لتحقيق صافي صفر بحلول عام 20 50
مؤتمر شرم الشيخ اعاده تاكيد على ضروره
العمل للحد من ارتفاع حراره الكوكب عند
درجه ونصف الدرجه المئويه بالرغم من
محاولات بعض الدول حذف هذا الرقم والتركيز
على ابقاء ارتفاع الحراره دون الدرجتين
والتي جاءت في اتفاقيه باريس المناخ لكن
بالرغم من تباته العمل على صعيد خفض
الانبعاثات قابل ذلك تسارع في وتيره العمل
على صعيد التكييف والتالم مع طبيعات
التغير المناخي حيث حقق مؤتمر شرم الشيخ
نجاحا استعصى على كل المؤتمرات المناخيه
منذ نحو ثلاثه عقود وهو الاتفاق على انشاء
صندوق لتمويل الدول الناميه لاغراض اعاده
بناء البناء التحتيه الضروريه التي تضررت
بسبب حالات الطقس العنيفه الناتجه عن
التغير المناخيه حيث عارض الدول الشمال
الغنيه لسنوات طويله تحمل اي المسؤوليه
قانونيه او دفع اي تعويضات عن حصتها
الضخمه من الانبعاثات التاريخيه بالتالي
فان الاتفاق على انشاء هذا الصندوق هو
بالفعل اتفاق تاريخي بالرغم من انه لا
يزال يعفي الدول الغنيه من المسؤوليه
القانونيه والتاريخيه لكن الامر لم يحسن
بكامله بعد حيث لم يتم الاتفاق حول كيفيه
تمويل هذا الصندوق وكيفيه تعريف الدول
المستفيده منها وترك هذا الامر لمؤتمر قبل
20 العمل المقبل اما على صعيد غاز الميثان
المسؤول عن نحو 30% من الاحتباس الحراري
القائم فقد انضمت خلال المؤتمر خمس دول
جديده الى تعهد المثال الذي اطلق في
كلاسكو العام الماضي ليرتفع عدد الدول
المشاركه في هذا التعهد من 100 دوله في
كلاسكو قبل عام الى 151 دوله في شرم الشيخ
وفي ما يخص اسواق الكربون الطوعيه فللاسف
لم يكن هناك اتفاق حاسم حول تحسين الرقابه
عليها وتوحيد معاييرها وزياده الشفافيه
فيها فما زالت هذه الاسواق تعاني من معضله
احتساب الكربون المخفض اكثر من مره وقد تم
تاجيل هذا الملف برمته للسنه القادمه
اذا بعض النجاحات وبعض الاخفاقات شهدها
مؤتمر المناخ قبطان في شرم الشيخ وهكذا هي
دائما المؤتمرات الدوليه لاسيما المناخيه
منها والتي تحتاج الى توافق جميع الدول
الا ان الرئاسه المصريه للمؤتمر تعاهدت
منذ البدايه بان يكون هذه السنه مؤتمرا
لتنفيذ ما اتفق عليه في المؤتمرات السابقه
تبقى العبره في التنفيذ خلال الاشهر
المقبله قبل ان يتم حصر ما تم تحقيقه وما
تم التاخر به مجددا في قب توينتي 8 في
الامارات العام مقبل
[موسيقى]
حول مخرجات
قابلت الدكتور عائشه السريحي الزميل
المشارك في معهد الشرق الاوسط في جامعه
سنغافوره الوطنيه وسالتها بدايه عن اهم
النجاحات التي حققها مؤتمر المناخ في شرم
الشيخ
والاضرار ضمن اجنده المفاوضات في مؤتمر
الاطراف وهذه هي المره الاولى التي يتم
ادراج
ومن ابرز مخرجات المفاوضات فيما يخص
الخسائر والاضرار هو انشاء صندوق لتمويل
الخسائر والاضرار
وايضا انشاء اليه حكمه لهذا الصندوق ما هو
صندوق الخسائر والاضرار يعني المشاهدين هو
صندوق التمويل يتم فيه نقل الاموال
المتقدمه والتي تسببت اساسا في
احداث الاحتباس الحراري واحداث تغير تبعات
تغير المناخ على الدول المتضرره نقل
الاموال من الدول المتقدمه الى الدول
المتضرره بتبعت تغير المناخي مثال على ذلك
هو الاضرار والخسائر التي شهدتها باكستان
من جراء حدوث الفيضانات همم في الفتره
السابقه
العديد من المراقبين اشاره الى اوجه قصور
او بعض اوجه القصور في مخرجات المؤتمر ما
هي مواطن الضعف والنقص التي اعترت تلك
المخرجات في رايك
في رايي ان هذا المؤتمر رغم النجاح الذي
حققه في انشاء صندوق تمويل
لاضرار والخسائر وكون هذا المؤتمر تم
استضافته في مصر ومصر هي كجوله ناميه تم
التركيز المفاوضات هذا العام على
انشاء صناديق للتمويل للخسائر والاضرار
وايضا لتحسين تكيف الدول مع اضرار التغير
المناقي
ذلك في الحقيقه اثر على همم ما هو اهم من
ذلك وهو مفاوضات التي تاتي بخصوص تقليل
انبعاثات الغازات الاحتباس الحراري وهو
المسبب للتغير المناخي ذلك يعني ان
التركيز تم على ايجاد الحلول لتبعات
التغير المناخي بدلا من ايجاد الحلول
لتقليل حدوث التغير المناخي
احتفاظ ااا وتقليل ارتفاع درجه حراره
الارض الى ما دون واحد فاصل خمسه درجه
سيليزيه
حلول اللي تمويل الاجراءات التكيف مع
التغير المناخي ولكن ليس حلول لتشديد
المستهدفات والتخفيضات في الانبعاثات
دعينا نعود من جديد دكتور عائشه الى مساله
الخسائر والاضرار وانشاء صندوق للخسائر
والاضرار الناتجه عن التغير المناخي التي
يعتبرها الكثيرون كما اا اعتبرتيها انت
النجاح الاهم لقمه شرم الشيخ ولكن هذا
البند اقر على اساس التعاون والتسهيل وليس
على اساس المسؤوليه والتعويض بمعنى اخر لا
تقر دول الشمال الغنيه بمسؤوليتها عن
الاضرار التي تتعرض لها الدول الناميه
جراء التغير المناخي الذي احدثته بالاساس
دول كمال ماذا يكشف هذا برايك عن معايير
اوروبا وامريكا او حقيقه عن ازدواجيه
معاييرها فيما يتعلق بالعمل المناخي وهل
يمكن ان ينجح هذا صندوق في ظل عدم اقرار
تلك الجهات عن مسؤوليتها
صندوق لتمويل الخسائر والاضرار فيما يخص
همم اعترافها بالمسؤوليه
بتبعاد التغير المناخي والدليل على ذلك ان
ادراج ملف الخسائر والاضرار همم اخذ حوالي
30 سنه الدول الناميه والدول الضرر التغير
المناخه كانت تنادي في ادراج هذا الملف في
مفاوضات المؤتمر همم منذ 30 عاما وتم
ادراجه همم هذه السنه فقط في مصر فهذا يدل
على ان هناك كانت تردد من الدول الغنيه
بالالتزام بتوفير التمويل للدول الناميه
والدول المتضرره اللي تبعات التغير
المناخي ولكن اريد ان انوه ان الاتفاق
الذي تم التوصل اليه في انشاء صندوق
للخسائر تمويل الخسائر والاضرار انما يدل
على ان هناك اتفاق بين
دول المتقدمه والدول الناميه والدول
المتضرره متابعات تغير المناخي ومن راي ان
هذا لن يؤثر همم او لن يلغي اليه عمل
الصندوق رغم وجود بعض الامور التي لم يتم
الاتفاق عليها في المؤتمر ما في ذلك اين
سيكون مركز هذا الصندوق وكيف يتم نقل وما
هي الدول المسؤوله عن التوفير الاموال
لهذا الصندوق وكيف يتم نقل الاموال من
الدول المتقدمه الى الديوان المحتاجه لهذا
التمرين كل هذه الامور سيتم مناقشتها في
المؤتمر الاطراف القادم السنه القادمه همم
الذي سينقل في دوله الامارات في دبي
طبعا هناك ايضا مساله تعريف ما هي الدول
الناميه المتضرره تعريف ما هي الدول
الناميه كانت اوروبا والولايات المتحده
تحاول عدم
الصين كاحدى الدول الناميه المتضرره همم
كون كما يقولون ان الصين في العقد
والعقدين الاخيرين اصبحت مصدر للانبعاثات
كبير همم جدا هي والولايات المتحده همم
ننتقل الى موضوع اخر دكتور عائشه ومصطلح
التخلي التدريجي عن الوقود الاحفوري هذا
المصطلح لم يجد طريقه الى البيان الختامي
في شرم الشيخ بالرغم من مطالبات البعض
بادراجه حيث تم الاكتفاء على ما جاء في
بيان كلاسكو العام الماضي حول التخلي
التدريجي عن الفحم فقط ولكن هذه المره لم
يكن من عرض هذه الفكره هم فقط الدول
الناميه ومصدرين النفط والغاز بل حتى
الاتحاد الاوروبي وذلك في ظل تبنيه للغاز
كوقود نظيف على المتوسط الى الطويل كيف
تقراين هذا الموقف الاوروبي
هذا الموقف الاوروبي انما يعكس اصداء
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا اصداء الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا انعكست في سيره
مفاوضات في مؤتمر الاطراف هذا العام فا
وايضا في الموقف الاوروبي فيما يخص
التخلي التدريج عن الوقود الاحفوري
اوروبا تعتمد بحوالي 45% من واردات الغاز
على روسيا وحوالي 35% من واردات النفس على
روسيا كان من الصعب على اوروبا حتى في همم
خططتها الاستراتيجيه في التخلي على همم عن
والدات همم
الوقود الروسي في خطتها الاستراتيجيه لم
تدرج التخلي عن الغاز انما ادرجت التخلي
عن النفس وهذا ايضا عكس في موقف الاوربي
في المفاوضات همم تقرير النهائي الذي خرج
من
مرحبا هذا العام لم يك لم يرفع سقف الطموح
فيما يخص من تقرير الاعتماد على الوقود
الاحفوري انما اكتفى بما تم ذكره في مؤتمر
جلاسكو من العام الماضي في مؤتمر الاطراف
همم السادس والعشرين وذلك بالتخلي
بالتدريجي عن الفحم وايضا التخلص من همم
عن همم
انواع المشتقات البتروليه والوقود
الاحفوري اخيرا دكتور عائشه كيف ستترجم
مخرجات مؤتمر شرم الشيخ
الى سياسات الدول العربيه كيف ستؤثر عليها
في الحقيقه انه
استضافه مصر
لمؤتمر الاطراف هذا العام وايضا كون ان
دوله الامارات ستضيف المؤتمر العام المقبل
هذا
انعكس على احداث نقله نوعيه في ما يخص
ادراج سياسات التغير المناخ في دول
المنطقه فلقد راينا حتى الان هنالك خمس
دول في المنطقه همم اصدرت همم توجه
بالالتزام بالوصول للحياد الصفري همم
بحوالي عام 2050 او60 بما في ذلك الامارات
همم سلطنه عمان السعوديه
وايضا الكويت همم وراينا ايضا ان بعض
الدول ايضا اصدر استراتيجيات همم متعلقه
والحد من التغير المناخي على المستوى
الوطني بما في ذلك ايضا الامارات
سلطنه عمان ومصر وايضا ااه راينا هنالك
توجه برفع سقف الطموح فيما يتعلق ايضا
بالاستثمار في مجال الطاقه المتجدده او في
مجال الهيدروجين
فمن راي ان الاستضافه همم دولتين عربيتين
لمؤتمر الاطراف على همم سنتين متتاليتين
في الحقيقه اثر بشكل فعلي في رفع مستوى
طموح الدول في ما يتعلق بتغير الحد
والتكيف من التغير المناخي
هل تنامي العمل المناخي والبيئي سيترجم
الى تعاون اكبر بين الدول ام انه قد يصبح
مصدرا جديدا للمنافسات بين دول المنطقه
لقد راينا الاثنين معا ااه نرى ان الدول
المنطقه هنالك نوعا ما نوع
من التنافس بين الدول
التوجه على سبيل المثال استثمار في مجال
الطاقه المتجدده الاستثمار في مجال
الهيدروجين واصدار سياسات على المستوى
الوطني للوصول لاهداف هذه الاستثمارات وفي
المقابل ايضا راينا ان هناك همم
تعاون همم الدول منطقه بدات تتعاون فيما
بينها في مجال همم التغير المناخ وعلى
سبيل المثال همم
اداره السعوديه الخضراء او مبادره الشرق
الاوسط نموذج على التعاون الاقليمي بين
دول المنطقه والذي يحفز عمليات التشجير
وايضا يستهدف انشاء صندوق تمويل لتغير
المناخي على مستوى المنطقه ويستهدف ايضا
انشاء مركز للابحا في مجال التغير المناخي
اااه ويركز ايضا على الحد من انبعاثات همم
الغازات الجفافيه على مستوى المنطقه
فمن رايه هنالك مزيج من الاثنين معا ومن
راى ان ذلك امر جيد جدا هذه المنطقه
بعده في مستقبل الطاقه
اختلاف المصالح يعطل الاتفاق الاوروبيه
على السقف السعري للغاز الروسي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد يواجه الاتحاد الاوروبي
صعوبات كبيره في الاتفاق على تحديد سقف
لسعر النفط الروسي المنقول بحرا وفقا
اقتراح مجموعه السبع فكره الصف الثاني هي
ببساطه الشحن والتامين واعاده التامين
الاوروبيه من التعامل مع شحنات الخام
المنقول بحرا ما لم يتم بيعها بسعر لا
يتجاوز السقف الذي ستحدده مجموعه السبع مع
حلفائها روسيا تبيع جزءا من نفقه الخام
عبر الانابيب لكنها تصدر ما بين 70% الى
85% بحرا عبر الناقلات ونظرا لوجود شركات
الشحن والتامين الرئيسيه في العالم في
الدول مجموعه السبع فان موسكو ستصبح امام
الخيار بين بيع النفط باقل من السقف
السعري او الاعتماد على اسطولها الخاص من
الناقلاتها
الخلاف بين الدول الاوروبيه يدور حول
المستوى الذي سيتم تحديد السعر عنده والذي
تقترح مجموعه السبع ان يكون ما بين ال 65
و70 دولار للبرميل
بولندا والتوانيا واسبانيا تريد سقفا
منخفضا قريبا من سعر التكلفه المقدر عند
نحو 20 دولارا بحيث لا تربح موسكو الكثير
من بيع النفس اما قبرص واليونان وملطا
فلديها الصناعات شحن كبيره ستتعطل اذا
توقفت شحنات النفط الروسيه ولذلك تلك
الدول تريد سقفا اعلى من 70 دولار للبرميل
بل وتطالب بتعويضات عن خساره الاعمال او
المزيد من الوقت للتكيف بحيث لا يتم تطبيق
سقف السعر في الخامس من ديسمبر كما هو
مقترح
بدوريها تتحضر روسيا للسقف السعري منذ
اشهر التوقعات تشير الى ان صادراتها
البحريه قد تنخفض بنحو مليون برميل من اصل
ثلاثه ونصف مليون برميل يوميا تصدرها
حاليا
هناك انباء عن بيع 60 ناقله من شركات
روسيه و70 ناقله اخرى يزيد عمره عن 15
عاما لمشترين غير محددي الهويه هذا العام
لتصبح خارج نطاق السقف الساري وعقوبه
مرتبطه بها لكن التقديرات تشير الى انها
روسيا تظل بحاجه الى 110 ناقلات اضافيه
لتفادي اثر العقوبات بشكل كامل
سيكون الامر تحديا صعبا لموسكو لكن فقط
اذا اتفقت الدول المناوله لها على السقف
السعري واليه تطبيقه وهو ما يبدو بعيدا
على الاقل حتى الان
[موسيقى]
في هذا مشاهدينا نصل الى ختام هذه الحلقه
من مستقبل الطاقه للمزيد دائما تابعونا
على تويتر تحت وسم هاشتاج مستقبل الطاقه
يمكنكم ايضا الاستماع الى كل حلقاتنا على
العربيه
وايضا مشاهده حلقاتنا كامله على موقعنا
على الانترنت العربيه دوت نت سلاش بروجرام
[موسيقى]